Bonjour,
pour commencer je citerai Abraham Lincoln qui disait:
«Aucun homme n’a assez de mémoire pour réussir dans le mensonge»
Il ne disait pas que des conneries mon frère jumeau!
Notre invité du jourest Franck,
c’est l’homme le plus mythomane du monde,
bonjour Franck.
-Bonjour.
C’est marrant, vous avez exactement la même voix que Grazminor.
Grazminor?
Parce qu’en fait à 15 ans j’ai été enlevé par des plutoniens,
les habitants de Pluton, et leur boss c’était Grazminor.
Et vous avez les mêmes intonations de voix donc du coup,
ça me fait rigoler.
Ben c’est normal, c’est parce que c’est super drôle.
-Oui je sais.
Mais à partir de quel âge vous avez commencé à raconter des mensonges,
c’est ça qui m’intéresse.
Ok donc le mec pose tout le temps des questions quoi.
On dirait Phil Collins.
Je le connais bien parce qu’en fait on est allé en colo ensemble,
et des fois il m’invite chez lui à Vegas,
et le mec pareil que vous quoi.
Tout le temps en train de poser des questions: «What do you do, what do you do?»
Sauf que lui il fait de la batterie derrière donc c’est plus sympa quoi.
Alors je vais le redire du coup:
à partir de quel âge vous avez commencé à raconter des mensonges?
Je peux pas répondre à cette question
je crois que le FBI nous observe.
Vous voyez ça,
c’est un micro.
Non, ça c’est mon téton...
Bien sûr! Un micro en forme de téton.
Ils sont forts.
Putain, est-ce que vous pouvez juste répondre à ma question s’il vous plait:
à partir de quel âge vous avez commencé à raconter des mensonges?
Vous savez, c’est vachement difficile pour nous de se donner un âge.
C’est qui «nous»?
Ben les vampires.
Putain! Je savais que … Putain!
Bon ok, ok, ok.  Je vous dis la vérité, un truc vrai, c’est sûr.
Je suis né le 3 mars 80 à Nice,
et je n’ai jamais connu mes parents.
Merci!
Du coup j’ai été élevé par deux tortues des Galápagos:
Miguel et Jean-Marc.
Le problème c’est qu’ils sont morts l’année dernière dans un accident d’avion.
En même temps Miguel n’a jamais été super bon pilote.
Vous allez me faire pleurer là en fait.
-Bon ok, je plaisante.
Je connais mes vrais parents.
Vous les connaissez d’ailleurs:
Brad Pitt et Mireille Dumas.
Ils ont jamais été ensemble.
C’est pas ce que dit le magazine Voizou.
Ce magazine n’existe pas.
Chez vous les humains, mais chez nous les cyborgs.
Stop! C’est bon, ça va, j’en ai marre.
Parce que là dans 5 minutes tu vas me dire que tu sais voler, ou j’en sais rien…
Chut.
Vers l’infini et au-delà.
C’est pas vrai.
Euh, bon, la semaine prochaine,
nous recevrons l’homme le plus en avance du monde. Soyez-là.
Putain!
C’est la semaine prochaine!
Je l’ai dit, c’est la semaine prochaine, tu dégages.
Ah non Madame, je suis pas un corbeau.
Arrête.
Et tu vois regarde, là c’est Vegas.
Et là c’est la maison de Phil Collins.
-Il faut que tu me lâches.
Eh Philou! On fait du tambour?
Est-ce que tu peux me lâcher?
Je vais pas te lâcher en plein milieu du Wisconsin! T’as même pas de GPS.